that was a great
moment uh back in 2006 uh the
opportunity to win our first World
Championship uh I recall that that game
in the fourth quarter when everything
was on the line uh besides having Dwayne
Wade and zo sort of dominate that game
in the fourth quarter it was UD making
three or four great jumpers and plays
you remember every single one of them
that helped us win that first
title yes and we're back there one of
those
three it's his day today it's a sad day
for me personally it's a great day for I
think the city of
Miami uh
because above us uh are players uh who
will go down in the history of this
franchise is some of the greatest
players that we've ever had obviously we
hang their jerseys with their name on it
uh they're right over here we don't have
Chris Bosch here or Shaquille O'Neal but
we're going to put up another one I like
this I like the fact that we have an
opportunity with everybody bearing
witness and especially his family and
all of you and whoever is next back
there of the young players that are
playing on the court tonight and some
veterans uh that will be the next and
there will be an next because there's
always great players that come around UD
is one of
them I know this for a fact that a
player's greatest fear is his fear of
Extinction but what he fears more than
that is to One Day become extinct with
ins significance and what that means to
me is that a player simply wants to know
that somewhere his career here his play
his personality his power his Force
mattered and it counted you Donis haslin
his Force mattered and it counted and
that's one of the reasons why we're
hanging his jersey here
today you don't merely want to be
considered the best of the best you want
to be considered the only ones who do
what you do there's nothing wrong in
separating yourself from the pack
there's nothing wrong in in making
yourself unique and to make sure that
one day you do leave Footprints Udonis
Haslam is going to leave a very big
footprint and that footprint right now
is going to lead right over here to this
jersey go to the
[Music]
Raptor for Thug baby the same that's why
the street still love me
baby see
I'm don't I blow your you your car get
my car in your ass so far you a off and
when I take off it's like I took off and
when I ride by it's like I fly
[Music]
by
way
[Music]
[Applause]
I want to say one thing to this guy over
here
Dwayne boy there's no way I'm sitting
here without you right now because I
used to think you was crazy for how
dream how big you used to dream but you
wern't crazy at all you showed me how to
dream you showed me how to dream and I
appreciate that dog all the things that
I'm doing now TV business and all these
opportunities because I watched you bro
I used to think you was crazy you had
you you had it figure out way before me
and I appreciate you for showing me how
to dream dog I love you to death brother
I'm going to keep dreaming man thank you
love you guys Miami Heat 305 for Life
heat Nation thank you love
[Applause]
you